focuses his toes we had we had a psychic
on a psychic medium Colby rebel and
Brian Moses what are your opinions on
psychic mediums you ever had an
experience with them or yes yeah my
current Wellings everything I thought it
would be like [ __ ] no tell me what wha
my current apartment might delay my
landlord at the time she's a psychic and
you had to pass her psychic reading just
to even get the signed application a
hundred percent and he let him in
another comic at Mars yeah she she was
in there for super cheap and I
absolutely how'd you get that place
she's like nobody gets this place but
you had to if you ever get a chance you
have to pass her psychic reading our
landlord the landlord and [ __ ] yeah she
took my psychic reading told me that so
many of my family close to me is gonna
die Annie it's what Annie said are you
know this is why I finally got the
reading yeah that's why I got like the
application I was like I got to get this
place so it was like 680 here in like
Los Angeles it's crazy yeah for yeah not
a big studio but like bigger than not
good yeah yeah that's cheap super cheap
in West Hollywood yes
yeah so yes take my reading how did she
read you just you know the to your lines
and yeah yeah so she's a psychic or
she's a palm reader or are those do
things both yeah I think it's its own
company with her and so what are you
what did she say she says somebody close
to my family is gonna die this year this
is back in 2014 maybe so yeah she's like
come here Wow
died this year nobody died a year but
was the following year they died yeah
because somebody always [ __ ] dies it
yeah I think that's why I was like yeah
so a close I know it was gonna die so
yeah obviously yeah it's nature in life
and then yeah I she said something Goods
gonna happen that's when we sold the
Rose bottle okay so Edison so what do
you think about that do you think you
think she had a gig reading ya know that
her psychic reading oh it was it was a
broaden that she was casting yeah yeah
it was like something good gonna happen
something Bad's gonna happen you can get
an apartment here I I mean you could
argue that that's good getting away so
what was it what was Annie Lederman also
had the same reading or something yeah I
think hers was different than most
Africa winters was nobody said it was
crazy talk to Annie she'll going to a
whole half-hour story about I can
picture my friends in Michigan right now
hearing this not that they listen but
going like is this what it's like in LA
there's some weirdos out here it yeah
your San Diego it felt typical la really
did I was like no way the psychic is
gonna [ __ ] yeah make sure ya hear
your San Diego though right
another I'm a military brat so it's
boring Los Angeles yeah I started
stand-up in San Diego okay cuz I don't
even think that would happen in San
Diego no that's very weird
no I mean maybe like on the beaches but
like yet not all over the county right I
do believe in that stuff besides your
landlord I tried not to I just feel like
so vain yeah I mean yeah like you I go
stuff like that's a vanity thing above
humans
yeah because I don't think there's
animals don't have that [ __ ] I don't
know well the Colby rebel psychic medium
who was here and read my dog Walter what
would say that he does put out
vibrations really she also air Walter
she goes on saying haunted I I don't
know but she did say to Aaron you like
your I feel your grandmother here but
you know also Aaron she set that off the
mic after the show was over and I was
like you really are anyways yeah I just
never never got into it right but I'm
wondering maybe I should open my mind to
it does she'll everything - every time
it means like have to go there but yeah
I feel like we should always be
open-minded and share this like alright
cool I can go this far yeah I mean I
think yeah I think you should I think
you should be open to hearing the pitch
word yeah yeah hearing the physics when
is your birthday Brian Moses June 1st
all right what'd you do this last one I
did nothing man this is what my Jesus
here so I just I chill why is this your
Jesus here what does that mean well it's
33 like you Jesus does oh is that a
common phrase I I just wanted to Bible
quick yeah
ladies guy but yeah so when you're 33
you know you chill or that means you
because that's how I mean like it was
not oft or he died right okay yeah so
they called you Jesus here okay from
what I understand damn you know from the
Bible community the time I'm heavy in
there so yeah no you're not having you
there but let's let's also talk about
when the roast battle did sell
we've had a lot of Roasters on in your
life
cool hurl K Trevor John the kid you have
gone well I was in Canada and with him
so I you know he was fun to get his take
on the roast battle because he's so nice
yes and I was like how did you go so me
and he's you know he said it saw it as
like a challenge exercise and he also
said people would be like hey make sure
you don't talk about her rape and he's
like I would never do that but like
that's how raw the roast battle can be
yes for our little Capel yeah he's like
I'm Canadian why would I ever like rape
tell tell my listeners about the roast
battle and how you started it rose
battle it I know this I know the learnt
prepared for this but but come on this
is not like it's yes oh yeah it really
is the rose petal is basically think of
a rap battle right over to guys are
basically just John back and forth
rhyming yeah this is more with guys who
have you know set up and punch but
they're their topic or their target is
the person they're looking at correct
so and it's now on its third installment
on Comedy Central what yeah we're we're
in talks to do a third season okay and
you guys this is a comedy show that it's
almost hard to explain you just kind of
have to watch it it's it's kind of like
Def Jam meets a rap battle meets a
boxing fight I mean it's like it's this
guy's like a punk rock out like a punk
rock concert it is nothing as his held
back you should have nothing's awful
nothing's off-limits literally the last
time I went to see the roast battle at
The Comedy Store one of the comics his
brother had just tragically passed away
three weeks prior and his opponent
entered as the ghost of his dead brother
I mean it is yeah it is rough sometimes
yeah are you sure are you and you
created it correct you know I say I know
I I don't say I created it they it's a
collective group it's a comic the Los
Angeles comedy community helped create
it for God's sake shut the [ __ ] okay
with you and a few other people's right
does a collective of people right okay
and you hosted it and the host is the
very first one
yeah correct all right so that's police
check out Rose Bell Brian is a humble
guy that's why people like him but it's
it's a super fun amazing show he also
was a stand-up comic ladies and
gentlemen a and your birthday is June
1st June 1st and we're in Bremen Marilyn
Manson or Meryl Monroe wrong Marilyn
okay well you know she Marilyn Monroe is
one of the more famous birthday
celebrations of all time when she sang
happy birthday miss - yeah exactly you
can see that on YouTube by the way
really crazy I'm gonna look at a blade
yeah I know the knot isn't not as
amazing as you would think but right the
dial phone game makes it seem so sexy
what was the telephone him it's almost
like when people put oh yeah oh right
okay yeah like oh yeah she was making
the cake about she's not going to
president a dick yeah uh what's your
worst version of my worst birthday was
my 18th birthday
wonderful yeah how about it so you have
18 you become legal right there you go
where were you living I was living in a
place called Ridgecrest California I
don't ever that yeah it's about three
and a half hour hours northeast of Los
Angeles okay it's literally it's the
military owns a million acres of land
out there so in the Mojave Desert so
it's my hobby deserts with no one
nowhere in the middle of nowhere it's
like it's the closest destinations are
Death Valley yeah which is and nothing
hold Death Valley I like he said it's
the middle of nowhere in the milk is why
would the military on this for like
testing and [ __ ] for bombs yeah for
bombs yeah they just bombs all the time
with it was you who in your family was
military dad was dead a type of military
ah Navy
he's a mechanic in the Navy and my mom
worked for the military
Wow I mean did you always know exactly
what they were doing no I thought you
know people ask I still don't know what
they do like I see aircraft mechanic now
just because I had to ask okay I don't
know what they do yeah I got on what my
mom does and she's done it for like I
don't know all my life meanwhile your
dad can't like unclog the the kitchen
game but he said he's in a really like
mechanic or there was there was a time
where I mean like you know obviously my
credits bad whatever cuz I was black
yeah there's that but it was so bad at
one point like my dad was like hey it's
messing up my my military access like my
class oh [ __ ] I was like
are you a spider [ __ ] yeah George you
were so much like that
yeah they had they go into your family
like you know I guess this guy okay that
is gotta kind of information yeah and he
was like upset with me I was like wow my
responsibility is like [ __ ] up your
weight suck it up the country right your
dad could be protecting us but but Brian
never paid his [ __ ] Boost Mobile yeah
I'm sorry about their repos yeah you got
your out of debt now yeah I'm good
working on her we could no I'm good now
yeah I mean that's great I love that I
wasn't in much debt I mean to be honest
I was like a kid who got credit cards no
I don't think I've ever had a credit
cards yeah I'm okay in fact and I don't
even know if I'm if it's okay for me to
share this one of the first gigs we ever
did together was in Atlanta right and we
stayed in bucket at that crazy night
hotel yeah you had to cover I had to
cover you on a credit card yeah doesn't
guess I trash the room you're [ __ ] up
everybody's life no but one of the
things I do like about show business
which there's not a lot of things the
one things I do like is when you see it
like this when the one success happens
to you or you see people we comics don't
make any money right and then when
something does happen you make money and
it's [ __ ] nice to be like okay good
your dad has full access now yes thanks
to the Rose silo right I I mean I'm
hoping that yeah I think yeah I mean
yeah something happened where he's like
I'm leavin know that kids yeah I don't
claim them anymore but yeah I think he's
been fun but that's beautiful how long
were you in the desert inside the desert
like there's gosh um we moved back and
forth like I want to say over there
maybe eight years of my life okay yeah
can you if I were to ask you of all the
cities you lived in could you name them
all yeah like no uh-uh
far bigger Inglewood California okay
military base the egg military El
Segundo is right there Lemoore
California which is near Fresno okay
Ridgecrest California China Lake which
is near nothing I've never heard it yeah
cities and then I uh and then yeah I
moved to San Diego okay I never say
anything about myself and after my 18th
birthday okay so what happened on the
birthday the birthday okay so I move out
I move out when I was like 17 I move out
like maybe six months prior
my birthday okay so I'm still in high
school but now I'm like I'm this
independent but you're in Ridgecrest
exactly I moved on how do you move out I
well you know I was that it was that
whole just angsty teenager thing I
thought I was in love with a girl yeah I
was like I'm moving out with her and her
best friend threesomes all the time my
mom had like a garbage bag like it was
so stereotypical was like I have my TV
yeah it's like yeah this itachi like
wooden box like you would never have
that TV today but yeah it like it was
just a bag of all my clothes like I
literally was and you went in from a
mile yeah and you and you went to get an
apartment in Ridgecrest yeah like going
but I got that at 17 I think that's an
eagle and I would almost the only guy on
the lease yeah that sounds illegal I
would also think all the housing would
be military housing there no there's
like it is like a segregated community
so there is a military base on the other
side this place Ridgecrest
which was founded by Mormons oh it was a
big Mormon community yeah yeah okay well
I think right he was now Wow founded by
Mormons no I do a little recap at the
end I like I remember stuff but re
relations in the daily show Thanks so I
thank you for nobody more deserving and
more qualified and thank God I love it I
pretty sure love it so much there was
one job for a straight white male in all
of entertainment because I think I guess
I'm trying really hard to not get fired
thank you very much um so you're 18
you're moving out mm-hm threesomes all
the time yeah I wish well yeah I wish it
was what's transpired my girlfriend
I learned a glib remove doubt that she
was I knew she had done drugs I wasn't a
big I was kind of a square in high
school I read a lot of drugs or any
drugs actually or drink but she was like
the sport athlete and then her best
friend dies and she became really
depressed and I had a crush on her she
was an old she's a year old and I was
okay anyway what well they were boring
little I thought it was not with a
cutter she was talking meth all the time
yeah like night like recreation like she
was addicted to it her and her best
friend all the races all the time I
thought threesome okay yes man all the
time so at like 1670 rolled girls yeah
yeah well 18 I guess I guess it doesn't
surprise me in the middle of nowhere in
the middle of nowhere but when you're
sixteen seven
you haven't learned this stuff yet right
yeah I mean now I'm thinking to Mike
well of course they were when I'm 37
lived a little bit of a life um admit I
mean it wasn't that it wasn't that
shocking she was doing it also she's a
black chicks I mean like if I'm not
gonna add like I said you know but yeah
that seems like it's not a black drug I
but I know her I know her drugs don't
discriminate right yeah that's our race
attack but I feel like meth to me it's
always seems like the white trailer
trash about 100 wide live like a big
white trailer trash you kind of talk
about it's this desert thing yeah this
what I think I think me and coach T's
from the same area and this will be
learned it's like is the DJ for
roseboro's battle sorry about that yeah
DJ coach he froze battle we grew up in
the same area um there's not really a
rich neighborhood there's not really a
poor neighborhood little is just we're
that middle class middle of the country
in rural California neighborhood yeah
it's just it's 25,000 people what was
there what was the race background of
this city because I would think military
is pretty nice right yeah the military's
diverse but then like I said segregated
so you have China Lake which is the
military base right it's a whole of the
community then you have this town rich
crush which is obviously all white
people all right all white Mormon poor
you mean one thing I really like about
the military and there isn't much is
that it does seem like they don't really
give a [ __ ] and I could be wrong but
they don't care too much about race and
ethnicity cuz they just want you to be
good at your job not anybody's anybody
your lab buddies I don't give a [ __ ] all
your you know I know you know sexual
orientation has become a thing there but
but it's like they don't give a [ __ ] but
anybody can protect the country right
yeah or kill some I mean how they treat
people in the service is a little
different yeah the most part they are
going to accept you in I can get in like
that that's one job you can get in it's
all you go to Facebook and it's all the
[ __ ] same types of people right yeah
like there's much different people okay
so um you find out that this chick is
just crushing math crushing men I mean
like her and her best friend are just
like I didn't know her best friend was
into it so her best friend used to date
my best friend okay right and then they
broke up and then I learned a year after
this happened that my friend had [ __ ]
my girlfriend oh my god hey Larry it was
awful yeah so I mean almost in the sense
the kind
back and I was like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
your ex-girlfriend yeah so much yeah
with Mike you know my current girlfriend
it's you [ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah so so
you move out I move out get this place
I'm 17 around bedroom are you living
with your girl two bedrooms yeah me my
girl and her best friend Billy have like
you know it's her friend's bedroom it
comes just like the meth den and I never
see my girlfriend wow yeah so I was I
was housing a trap house so how how do
you first of all how did you not know he
was on drugs overfunding well how did
you not know she was on drug before you
like how long were you dating each other
we were dating for we'll see it was 17
years I started dating her I'm 17 and
then I was like just I was in all right
this is it I yeah I found it yeah as you
are yeah Aventine and you finally get
[ __ ] for the firm so they're crappy
that was an idiot yeah so then in all my
idiocy I I told my mom I'm like I'm in
love I'm leaving here you know you don't
like her I love her yeah we're doing
this man yeah I don't know what you're
talking about yeah of course that sounds
great
right so then yeah I move out it to me
her and their friend and then I cease to
see my I cease to see her
sar they smoking are they doing live
like it it's pro it's like it's before
the propane tank or the butane thing
became like popular I guess it was the
dabbing of the marijuana can be done
right you don't get it but I'm saying it
was it would like like lighter torches
they were crazy Wow
and then yeah they like pipes all over
like you know their room and you go in
the room it looked like a like a Crypt
Keeper lived there it was crazy it was
dark and so when did you get out and
when did the birthday fall into all this
[ __ ] um so a week before I graduate high
school maybe two weeks it's my birthday
June 1st and my whole family you know
flies up because I wanna say at this
point it's like what - in the road to
thousands it's still kind of a big deal
when a black kid graduates from cut from
night college from high school a little
big things about everybody in your in
your family graduate from high school
you know later go and get jobs or you
know who's so is that not as big of a
deal now it's not a big of a deal now
that's good right happy exactly this is
the address it's like this this is the
most time in history that blanket
lectures on to college now so now that's
that's more of a feat more than just
you're out of high school thank you
thank is that evolution is that Obama is
that that's evolution that's yeah you're
talk about 40 years in the into Brown
versus Board of Education yeah
are you talking about immigration yeah
under any schools works I mean I
remember like might when my thoughts
obviously raised divides that as well
but right so does so so can economics my
father graduated college and my dad grew
up really poor like nobody right there
they knew anybody to go to college that
was outlandish and so my sister just did
it she the first in her family ever it
isn't amazing I mean are you talking
about I was Devon teen and that's going
to change your family's course forever a
hundred or so yeah and I remember when I
graduated high school all of my dad's
family like we all drove in and [ __ ] and
right it's still a big deal like it why
are you you know like I'm supposed to
graduate high school but like that
that's that's where they come okay so
your graduate everyone's coming in
everyone's coming in and I'm like you
know I'm a seventeen year old - well I
don't care I'm like I got this girl
she's on drugs I'm trying to deal with
her so I was more I was more concerned
about her well-being so I was like I was
trying to get this chick off meth and
like into my bedroom more but she ever
try to get you to do meth no you know
it's weird you could taste it oh my god
go down honors gnarly I mean there was
all week no of course what doesn't make
you freak this you got gonna check but I
was like I going down on the group all
that that's another matter breaking I
mean and you graduate high today
Wow threat everybody high so you could
taste the math you could lose a super oh
it was yeah well that does make sense
because it's like if when women
breastfeed you can you nishan do you
taste the math that you can hit the fast
when he's doing you suck milk out of but
we should have asked Cara Santa Maria
Cara Santa Maria it was our last guest
and I keep on her car up because I have
a friend named Cara but her name is
Karen it's spelled the same hmm who
gives a [ __ ]
here's the thing okay everyone is coming
into town and you're trying to get your
girlfriend off of mess right what's
happening so mom comes on my birthday
right
mm-hm and I didn't expect it cuz we had
a falling-out obviously she you know I
turned my back on them basically a
little bit but your mother and father is
still together yeah and they were like
and I yeah they were different yeah I
didn't really see my dad all I grown up
because he was in the military and he he
would have to keep going to these places
and my mom was like we're not gonna keep
moving the kids around sure
let's stay in one spot yeah so I
graduate high school risk wrist
okay um so she was like yeah she was
like the closest person to me so
obviously I had the song with her and
I'm just I'm really mean to her sure
she's the closest person to me I hear I
know I hurt her right yeah okay and
what's this what's the chicks first name
good method would you mind sharing that
Renae all right
typical method we might no matter what
Brian said that's what I was going to
say all right citizen s okay Michael
typical typical Mike so you're
graduating relays on maths it's a week
for graduate but they're all getting
here a week earlier right and then I
just you know just to be out in
California you know people from the
South or not from California Pasqua yeah
and yeah Brian's graduating high school
they all fly out mom comes and says hey
could you do me a favor and just act
like you didn't do this and just come
see how come come see the family can
it's all you yeah I'm like a camp and we
when she says act like you didn't do
this that means move out I mean like
don't be a jerk yeah you know okay like
yeah you moved out but like don't flaunt
it I just just come and be a real
spectable young man because those people
spend some money to come see you is that
a fair request a hundred percent was
exactly I checked they were like what
first of all is pressure on me but I'm
just still this young angsty jerk I'm
just like I don't care yeah I got my own
place yeah I don't have to see you
people you know I mean I'm gonna
graduate not talk to them beat it [ __ ]
and I say something like that to her I'm
like no I just keep saying no and she's
just crying at my door so it's my
birthday but like in the middle
afternoon I'm dealing with this [ __ ]
passed out person on the couch because
she's like she's too strung out she's
gotta go to work later and then my mom
is like at the door like what you please
come see your family this is so funny
Brian because I've known you for a long
time and you're always so positive and
smiley yeah is this I don't ever seen
this side of you
and maybe I haven't seen it is this real
you or didn't cares oppress'd little why
because I'm remember we talked to this
earlier like you have a worst birthday
you could ever talk about this thing
last time I think we did yeah la jolla
together dancing and then I was like I
don't think I do and then you asked this
I was like well there was oh my god my
18th birthday yeah I did I think I
forgot about that period of time because
that was a really seventeen to twenty
was a really weird period of my life
where I was just obsessed with
woman yeah I was destroying my life
interesting yeah I mean look that's not
I hope it gives you comfort to know
that's not uncommon but for everybody
just learning that in this field yeah of
course yeah I mean but but to fall in
love with someone that is detrimental to
your life and probably it comes from you
wanting to help her right that's what
I'm into I'm a codependent I love yeah I
need a project you think of that [ __ ]
girls you hear that Ryan ever like I'm
broke now I don't know if what I like a
broken I really what's your Twitter
handle a trace
banning RAC what is that you know like
you know race Bannon from a Jonny Quest
I don't know that all right a trace
banning and then if you want to hit him
up on Facebook or was what Facebook is
Brian Moses Brian Moses he like he likes
a project lady they do a love a project
so mom's crying on your doorstep crying
oh man you know pleading yeah
he was trying to be strong about it to
not being like you know she knows I'm
being a jerk so she can't give me too
much and I'm seeing that I'm just being
a young idiot you know it's like no mom
no I was more concerned about what was
happening in my in my house then I you
know her trying to say face or us you
know yeah I should have been a jerk yeah
yeah uh so then yeah I my birthday she
gives me she gave me a birthday card oh
that I didn't know that breaks my heart
it broke my heart I forgot about that as
I think about this today I was like oh
my gosh she gave me that yeah she gave
me birthday cards like like standing in
front of you pleading feud I said okay
crying give her the card walks off and
did you ever see the family then that
was there I ended up being I ended up
when I graduated I end up seeing them
yeah for a little bit afterwards like a
solid couple hours I probably shoulda
spent the whole night but yeah you
should have and and they were all cool
about I mean I think there was more
morning every just proud so I think that
kind of masks mmm
masked my my idiocy I also think I hope
maybe maybe we we come up with this to
make ourselves feel better I do think
everybody remembers being 17 and members
of that you sometimes did the wrong
thing right like they were probably like
I was very typical though I thought was
gonna be a different cause I'm never
going that far as civil lawyers but you
gotta like older people are a little
more understanding like he's 70 he's got
to figure this [ __ ] out on his own mm-hm
so how did you and your mom mend this
event
you'll know the real reason yeah so I
need to be getting this chick pregnant
here we go stop a minute 24 here's the
good so early yeah you end up getting
the [ __ ] meth head pregnant got her
pregnant Mike I mean like we move out of
this place at me her and her best friend
right we don't have a falling out but I
mean I haven't finally with my
girlfriend like I can't do this until
tonight him yet to choose me at the
drugs yeah she chilled the drugs so that
I moved out and then her friend of the
falling out because they can afford the
apartments none of them were working I
mean it's their attics so everything is
going to crumble around them the drug
will be the priority right for
everything okay it was and then so I got
another place and then she begged and
pleaded to move into that place two
months after we had broken up or
whatever yeah I succumbed obviously yeah
and then yeah I end up getting pregnant
after that and and then that's when you
and your mom asked me he had some help
finally or would know but the story was
this this is what happened it was the
night I me my girl from having a worry
just it's just not working you know it's
like yeah her her uncle gets out of jail
and he sells meth right Jesus cry as in
hit this chick she was like whaaat she
was the hottest like shivers my black
Barbie there we go
still hot I feel however uh uh yeah but
um look you're hanging around here Aaron
oh my god uh so yeah so anyway so she's
just housing these I would come home
from work as you take the craziest
people just like talking fast and taking
things apart in my house and I'd be like
what am i funding you know taking things
apart cuz I doesn't method thing yeah
they'll they'll take things apart to fix
and they'll never put it back together
so why is that a meth thing it's just
like I don't know it's not a crack it
then crack it
they sell things then yeah yeah they're
not taking things apart they're just
like oh and a soap and heroin you fall
asleep right Nadia you become like a
great musician Yeah right uh coke you're
just annoying as [ __ ] yeah talk a lot
yeah a little great comic also great
comic yeah um Methos I I've heard this
before like all my neighbors of meth out
doing what do you mean you can hear em
in the middle of the night taking a part
of Ned and [ __ ] right so it must do
something to the brain that's like
deconstruct right it's actually it's
it's weirdly productive yeah but then
it's not because they never put it back
together that's so annoying
it's weird as [ __ ] yeah so toaster would
be like she's like I'm gonna fix him
like there's nothing wrong with it and
she's gonna make it better I'm like all
right I'm going to trust this over here
17 yeah I mean or make sure the thing
that isn't broken yeah never did I never
did that's all we took it apart with
there were so many things around the
house were taken apart yeah I was like
we need to put the stuff back together
oh man yeah you are codependent yeah
soldier uh yes mussels out he saw Ahmet
beating his girlfriend she was coming
over like hiding out anyway I uh I end
up you got her pregnant because because
you know shocked I'm inside her hobby
who's doing that but she'd be like we
would say she would say this to me she's
like no don't work on see more like
let's not do that I just don't think a
Discovery Channel oh my god and she's
like if I just have an orgasm the next
day it kills all the sperm oh my I'm
like every channel never lies that's
that smart [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry years old
I know so so yeah Wow totally
caller:thank say like hey did you did
you masturbate million orgasm - like I
got it and for like two weeks it was
working was she was she trying to trap
you know she had no she was on drugs on
drugs no idea okay okay so then uh I'm
doing all this I get her pregnant right
um
we're like stealing prank success for my
Kmart it was so just poor and just
stereotypical uh hidden uh uh by the way
it's okay yeah yeah you know this okay
and we were fine and I was like you know
what maybe she's not you know and then
uh the I was like I'm gonna let me talk
my parents cuz of me a hero having a
falling out anyway I was like moving
back in anyway like I'm yeah she's
pregnant yeah everything's fine
at the end of the day you knew mom was
like solid they wanted it yeah they
wanted me to come back me to just know
the error of my ways
yeah which is this woman yeah right
right so then I'm having dinner with
them and like I asked them to look like
a dad's there - yeah dad's their
attorneys I was like hey you know listen
I'll finish schools let me move back and
I can't do this anymore
and they're like it's all one to here
literally I want to say 40 minutes after
I I hear that from them I'm hanging out
they get call from her she's like I'm
pregnant
oh my god that's what yeah and they
should have miscarriage okay like a week
later
usually a miscarriage doesn't get an
applause break but I am happy did it
happen because that sound like
the baby would have been [ __ ] out this
oh yeah that's why I said I was like in
oh maybe she does in to save her life
and that was a problem everybody thought
the baby would change everything
yeah it doesn't no I mean I don't I
don't have any kids that yeah is she
clean now or anything oh she's clean
she's got you know yeah she lives in San
Diego now she owns a place she owns a
couple luxury cars
breno yes yeah she guess she graduated
she cleaned it all just so beautiful oh
oh geez
well James yeah hey um so it was just a
dark kind of sad time for you yeah Wow
what's your relationship with your mom
and parents like now it's great I saw
him at the roast battle all there I mean
they're just they're the proudest people
ever I make sure you know I've always
been just such a jerk to them but
they've always been great and they I
think that's what maybe being a parent
is about doing it's kind of you had to
endure it sucks and you just get [ __ ] on
forever and then you still love this
person and then when you die that person
feels guilty forever and that just like
it just keeps happened right through all
of you I mean all they did was support
they were never there never Dix yeah
that's really great yeah um I like to
finish with a great birthday and I don't
like to ask you to come in prepare whoa
what is a great birthday you've had that
you can think of as a kid maybe as an
adult when did you get the news that
Rose battle got picked up was it ever in
New Year dad was early in the year and
had how did they break it to you phone
uh yeah it was Jeff Ross Jeff Ross
called me told me he's like yeah we got
all your dreams are coming true yeah I
was like all right and then six months
later they found everything so so
Christmas work so all your dreams are
coming true then they call back and say
I canceled that yeah it's in development
that's taking long times
so what's it what's a great birthday
come on the greatest birthday ever um
we're just one that you remember that
was really good I'm trying to thank me I
think it was yeah maybe I was like 10 or
15 years old it was I was right around
when the OJ was like driving around I
remember that so about June 17th I 94 so
right so but so that data does memory is
better than you yeah yeah it's more like
being the younger the better was like I
was like the 90-degree
being young and black I don't know what
it was it was awesome because like the
riots were happening
oh she was happening it was like there
was so much white guilt it was so dope
yeah yeah yeah I never thought of it
that way but as a black man myself I
never trust all right guy black dick
I'll tell you this right now the only
thing I remember the 90s is relived
every time I go to XM Radio's 90s
channel and it worse music yea nineties
but 90s hip-hop is good right right yeah
hands over there of the golden mm but
everything else was just terrible
because groans whoo school backspin will
play 90's hip right nineties channel is
like a garbage you Sherman SiriusXM
right now funds best birthday I want to
say I was probably six or seven and we
went to Chuck E Cheese I got so much
Ickes cheese this was always magical
yeah we could it was every mm every
fantasy of a kid right playing no rules
[ __ ] animatronic Mouse and strong
molesting kids yes
Brian Moses where can everybody find all
your information I just go to verbal
violence TV that's it right that's the
one powerful violent about TV please
check out the Rose battle please check
out Brian Moses a stand-up comedy I want
to thank you for sharing your worst
birthday thank you for having best of
luck to you and graduations again man
thank you honestly could connect a
better person thank you Brian Moses you
guys thank you very much that's great
dude